if you want to put the
odds in your favor and get the
results you need
maximize your english skills
with a world class course at the
british council as a
world expert in teaching english
we can immerse you in 20
languages that will support your studies in on
of our centers or online and since
English is the inter
ational language of business it is
essential that you feel confi
ent in English to achieve your goals
we ca
create the perfect formula for y
ur needs with  dipl
recognized throughout the world
our teachers are experts and know how
to help you gain confidence in
oral and written expression and comprehension
and prepare you for exams
such as the rts through courses
specially designed through our
interactive courses and our resources  online
you will have access to world-class
educational materials designed
to assess and develop v  our
learning wherever you are in the
world
we have a solution for you
with the best range of courses and
support in the world we can
help you access higher education
in an institution that suits you
and towards a successful future
optimize  your university studies
through our English centers or an
online resource with world experts
in teaching English